Muffet McGraw led the Notre Dame women's
basketball team to the NCAA Final Four
this season for the ninth times the
Fighting Irish ultimately lost to Baylor
by just one point McGraw also drew
attention for her powerful words about
gender inequality I'm getting tired of
the novelty of the first American the
first female governor of this state the
first female african-american mayor of
this city when is it begun to become the
norm instead of the exception how are
these young women looking up and seeing
someone that looks like them preparing
them for the future we don't have enough
female role models we don't have enough
visible women leaders we don't have
enough women in power and when these
girls are coming out who are they
looking up to to tell them that that's
not the way it has to be and we're
better to do that than in sports the
Basketball Hall of Famer has a better
than 77 percent winning record in her 32
years at Notre Dame she has been named
coach of the year four times by The
Associated Press McGraw joins us first
on CBS this morning since her headline
making comments good morning good
morning
they resonated not just with women with
men too my dad who of course brought up
your comments what does it mean that we
don't have enough women in power and
what effect does that have well I think
it has a huge effect on our daughters
and when we look at the next generation
of women who are they looking up to to
say this is what I want to be when you
have less than five percent of the CEOs
in Fortune 500 companies or women if you
look at the in the Senate in the house
we're just so far behind and if girls
aren't growing up and they're not going
to the movies and they're seeing things
that are directed by women about women
with leading women getting paid the same
as men they come out and what do they
learn they learned that men are gonna be
the lead and men are going to be in
charge and yet we had title 9 to change
things and yet nearly 80 percent of all
college athletic directors are men what
do you think is key to hiring more
female coaches well I think people hire
people who look like them and you have a
lot of white men in athletics especially
as the athletic director and they're
gonna hire a lot of men because they're
comfortable with that they're gonna look
at the guys on the men's side and say
hey why don't you come over and coach on
the women's side
we never do the reverse and I think it's
just so important and the way women go
for jobs we need to be more aggressive
but what did your passion come from
though that day because were you
intending to say that at that particular
time in that particular place you know I
was not intending to say that I don't my
friends ago where did that come from but
you know we had just come through Black
History Month then we had Women's
History Month and I saw someone say why
don't we have men's History Month and I
said because men's history is taught in
school we learn about men in the
curriculum we know all about what men
did when I think back what woman was
famous in history when we were in school
and Betsy Ross you know and she was
famous for sewing so where are all these
great accomplished women yeah but yeah
but I heard people say why did she have
to say it why don't you just do it why
was it important for you to say it
because people could say now you're
discriminating against men you know I
and I did do it about I've had an
all-female staff probably for the past
eight years I have had men on myself and
I do hire men I have a video coordinator
and a sports information I do hire men
but on my staff I think it's important
for the women that we're coaching to
look up to that staff and see that and
it's just we've been so successful we
have great chemistry I think it's just a
great situation I wish when my former
players came out looking for jobs I wish
more women we're able to get those jobs
but they're just not out there how much
of this is a message that you convey to
the young women that you coach they get
that message all the time any time a
prominent woman comes on campus we had
kind of Lisa Rice come by a couple of
weeks ago we have them come over and
talk to the team because I want them to
see these successful women there really
aren't that many of them I want to talk
about the numbers because this was
stunning to me I touched on title nine
when it was enacted in 1972 ninety
percent of the coaches of female
basketball teams were women now it's
down to 41 percent
I thought title nine was supposed to
guarantee equality in education and
sports wife the number decreasing well
that was the idea and when it came out
of course it took 30 years probably for
us to get to any kind of equality when
I'm not sure was still there what
happened was when we got to the point in
the 90s they started paying more that's
when the men came in suddenly the salary
was worth their time coming over from
the men's side they couldn't break into
the men's game here's an opportunity on
the women's side to make some money
we've looked at the u.s. women's
national soccer team we've covered that
story for the first time now all of them
are going to sue for equal pay
are we the transformational moment do
you think with women in sports well I
really hope so we thought maybe when
Billie Jean King started that years ago
that we things would change and now the
women's soccer team is stepping forward
and making a big push and maybe we'll
see something from the WNBA what still
needs to be done Lots needs to be done I
think first it starts with hiring women
and I think if girls aren't looking up
and seeing these role models how are
they gonna learn what it's supposed to
be like and how are they gonna believe
that they can do it and if they can't
believe it how are we gonna change it
Budaj is your mayor he said you are a
leader that he admires what do you think
about mayor Buda jizz I think he's
awesome I was down there for his
announcement on Sunday he's somebody
that is a great voice and he's got a
different perspective than we've had
he's young he knows this generation and
I think he's the future can I just say
you're the first Buffett I've ever met
what is the name on your birth
certificate it was not Muffet but it is
on my driver's license now it's my legal
name you don't want to tell me what it
is well it is an my mom's name was Ann
nobody cuz here's Muffet her husband
Matt is here and they have a son Murphy
I'm thinking him as a great letter at
your house
congratulations on being on thank you 48
women top 48 women that means a lot
coming back